vor einer woche stand ich schon einmal
hier vor diesem altenheim erhalten haus
und sankt nikolaus in würzburg damals
war hier der tod des ersten bayerischen
kroner patienten zu vermelden
das war ein 83 jahre alter mann bei dem
war am sonntag zuvor der virus
festgestellt wurden er kam ins
uniklinikum würzburg aber er war so
schwer erkrankt auch an der lunge das zu
ihnen nichts mehr zu tun war mit ihm war
sein mitbewohner aus der wohngruppe ein
82-jähriger eingeliefert wurden auch er
verstarb dann kam es im laufe der woche
zu einer immer größeren dynamik er am
dienstag waren es bereits vier tote aus
dem alten haus sankt nikolaus und heute
am freitag sind es also stand jetzt 9
wir wissen dass zehn weitere patienten
senioren aus diesem haus alle über 80
das virus in sich tragen oder auch
verlegt nur noch in ihrem zimmer zu
bleiben
zudem dürfen auch pfleger ihr zimmer nur
mit mundschutz betreten
besonders dramatisch ist es natürlich
auch für das pflegeheim selbst 160
bewohner hier
und 23 pflegerinnen haben ebenfalls
corona den virus in sich und mussten
unter quarantäne gestellt werden
das alles macht die hälfte aller corona
fälle hier in würzburg aus am dienstag
waren das 80 ich weiß du hast mit
pflegern oder pflegerinnen dort
gesprochen was sagen die dir dort muss
doch eine erhebliche angst herrschen in
diesem altenheim dass sich das virus
eben weiter auf alle bewohner ausbreitet
und möglicherweise auch weitere tote
gekostet
der träger dieser einrichtung ist das
bürgerspital lupburg eine stiftung und
man versucht dort natürlich alles diesen
virus auch auf der etage zu halten wo er
ursprünglich festgestellt wurde
ich habe tatsächlich heute abend mit
einer pflegerin sprechen können die mir
auch ein wenig die reaktion der
angehörigen geschildert hat man kann
sich vorstellen dass da viel
verunsicherung ist vielleicht auch viel
mut aber sie sagte das hätte es
eigentlich nur ein
einen fall gegeben wo es also vorwürfe
gegen das pflegeheim gab als man ihnen
dann den angehörigen mitgeteilt habe
dass das seniorenheim dafür eigentlich
nichts dran hätten sie sich auch wieder
entschuldigt es ist wohl so dass der
virus von außen eingeschleppt worden ist
man wollte nicht genau sagen auf welchem
weg es hieß nur dass sich derjenige der
ihn zuerst hatte ihn vielleicht auch in
einem krankenhaus sie sich zugezogen hat
sich infiziert angesteckt hat und ihn
dann in dieses seniorenheim mitgebracht
hat und das altenheim derzeit
abgeriegelt oder wie geht man damit um
nein also das landratsamt hat auch
gesagt dass es momentan
unverhältnismäßig wäre dieses heim zu
evakuieren
es gelten wie gesagt schutzmaßnahmen
reinigungskräfte pflegekräfte müssen
alle nur mit mundschutz hinein
es gilt natürlich seit vergangenem
freitag ein striktes besuchsverbot was
ja heute auch noch mal immer lass der
staatsregierung geregelt wurde
das war wohl auch das vordringliche was
viele der angehörigen auch der
betroffenen so bewegt hat dass sie ihren
ja vätern müttern in diesen schweren
letzten stunden teilweise nicht
persönlich bein stehen konnten dank jörg
völkerling für diese informationen und
eindrücke aus würzburg von dieser
dramatischen corona lage in einem
altenheim alleine neun todesopfer durch
corona